here's something that I think about
frequently is that if you're exploring
any topic and or if you're doing
research in any topic I think you should
explore the boundaries and have an
answer to the question of what could the
answer possibly be that would make me
burn my hands for and and not
investigate this for instance AI that
they could be creating the tools of
civilization's demise and they need to
be thinking about that deeply yeah and
same with Richard fan said this about
the bomb they weren't thinking about the
they were just so fascinated by the
physics it was just fun to do research
they weren't thinking about how many
millions of lives would be destroyed how
horrific and how the world would change
forever I am Shiva the destroyer of
worlds or whatever like yeah